bitcoin's been the best performing asset
over the last 10 years and there's a lot
of people who are trying to figure out
how should they think about it some
people compare it to an internet stock
other people compare it to gold and some
people they simply think it's a
speculative tool but recently more and
more bitcoiners are being asked to go on
national television some people want to
celebrate the fact that the price is
going down they think that they're going
to dance on grapes but other people
they're trying to get to the bottom of
it they're trying to find truth what
exactly is this digital currency how
should people think about it is it
something that they should put in their
portfolio
well natalie brunell recently went on
fox with charles payne and he asked
exactly how she thinks about the macro
environment and how bitcoin fits into it
here's a piece of that interview so i
got less than a minute to go in your
mind walk us through the script what
happens next it seems like you're
inviting regulations and i don't blame
you by the way the bad news all this bad
stuff that's happened it is a learning
lesson it's a tough learning lesson but
now what happens that we make sure that
some of these safeguards have put in and
that bitcoin can start to really live up
to to the potential
yeah sure so we just need more clarity
we already know bitcoin is a digital
property and digital commodity but we do
need fair accounting so more
institutions come in we need a stable
coin that people can trust and we need
these tokens that are unregistered
securities to be declared as such so
that they have proper disclosures proper
filings and i think all of that will
happen and i think all of it will be
good for bitcoin and then on a macro
picture i think we have to watch what's
going to happen with inflation i think
we might see a short-term bear market
rally followed by some more pain and
ultimately i think the fed is going to
have to pivot and i really want to
mention charles before i go people
should really listen to what putin just
said about the global financial system
because he called out the u.s for our
money printing policies and asked why
countries should exchange goods for
dollars and euros when they're losing
value so quickly because of inflation
and money printing and he's predicting a
world that moves away from treasuries
and sovereign debt and that means in my
opinion that bitcoin is coming for bonds
and that's a way bigger market cap than
gold now there's a key piece that i want
you to pay attention to natalie snuck it
in right at the end she said that
bitcoin is coming for the bond market
and that's way bigger than gold one of
the key things that happens in the
global financial system is that everyone
over the last couple of decades has
treated the united states and our bond
market that's a safe haven a place that
you could find some sort of security if
all of a sudden people stop trusting
those bonds if they stop looking for
sovereign debt and they simply say we
need to store economic value in some
other asset if bitcoin has apolitical
money that doesn't adhere to any one
country and isn't controlled by any
individual or any organization can rise
to global prominence all of a sudden
bitcoin as a neutral asset could replace
that bond market now that's a big big
claim and it may seem very unlikely
today but if you look over the next 30
to 50 years the united states and other
developed countries they've taken their
fiat currencies they're continuing to
devalue them they can't support their
debt they're not growing fast enough and
so many folks that are used to using
those major currencies are asking
themselves is this the right strategy or
should we look elsewhere
bitcoin as of today has a chance to rise
to replace all of that sovereign debt as
a safe haven asset where these other
countries these other organizations
these other corporations will want to
hold economic value for the long run now
again no one has the crystal ball no one
knows how this plays out but bitcoin
going after the bond market is much much
more exciting than going after the gold
market
natalie's point here is well take it and
i think you're gonna hear more and more
people talking about this over the
coming years
bitcoin
serves as a bond
for the people who actually treat it as
their reserve asset
cash and cash equivalents
now maybe it's going to be bitcoin
and bitcoin
that would be a crazy world that we'd be
moving towards but it's one that's
becoming more probable with each passing
day hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time